The old proverb goes "Incest is best, so put
your brother to the test".
Today we'll examine the validity of this statement.....for
science......Do we have a barf bag off set
just in case?
Hey everyone, Laci Green here.
It's everyone's favorite subject: incest!
No really.
It seriously feels like incest is now everyone's
favorite topic.
It's a big Japanese porn thing, it's a big
Game of Thrones thing....a big yahoo answers
thing.
Oh, humans.
Incest is a moral dilemma as well as a scientific
one.
Few things provoke such disgust---for MOST
people---as the idea of having sex with a
blood relative.
Of course non-consensual sexual contact with
a family member is a form of abuse and absolutely
not OK, but what about when it's consensual
and they're not having kids?
It's hard for a rational person to reason
out of, and yet that disgust is still goin
strong.
But, this is science time, because YAY DNEWS,
so let's talk about incest or inbreeding from
a scientific standpoint.
A recent report in the open access journal
PeerJ found that inbreeding in woolly mammoths
from the North Sea may be why they went extinct.
The researcher's main clue was cervical ribs
on the neck of the fossils.
These ribs are known to develop when genetic
or environmental disturbances take place while
the embryo is developing.
There are also other birth defects that are
associated with this mutation and the scientists
believe those abnormalities could have played
a role in the mammoth's ability to survive.
Now, mammoths aren't the only species speculated
to have inbred - in fact most species will
inbreed if it's the only option.
Other animals known to inbreed often are...house
cats.
Bonobos practice incest as part of social
bonding, and in some species of wasp, over
90% of them mate with their brother or sister.
It's a strange paradox given the hell that
inbreeding can wreck on the offspring.
Inbreeding basically means that there's no
diversity of the genetic pool.
So, bad genes are magnified.
With...ummm...outbreeding?
Is that a word?
Basically how it goes down is that when humans
breed with non-relatives, the offspring gets
2 copies of a particular gene, so if one copy
isn't good, they have a normal one as backup.
Inbreeding, particularly over many generations,
completely eliminates these backups across
hundreds or thousands of genes, which can
cause some weird mutations and exaggerations
of genetic defects.
It will also cause fertility issues eventually.
Even though there are several species, including
humans, that practice incest and inbreeding,
the majority of the animal kingdom rejects
incestuous advances in normal circumstances.
It's thought that different species have evolved
different mechanisms to make sure they don't
put their genes at risk.
For humans, that mechanism may be a combination
of psychological systems -- including the
scent of their pheromones and facial detection.
I know incest is kinda gross, but when you
think about that disgust as a possible evolutionary
response...it's actually kinda interesting.
Let me know what you think down below and
I'll catch you next time with more DNews updates.